Hi guys, I'm Erik Voss
and Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2 is here,
and I can't wait to talk about it.
But quickly, I'm going to break down the post-credits scenes.
Now, I'm sorry if there is a bit of an echo in here.
We're moving into a new studio,
which you can't really tell because it's the same blue screen, but I'm not lying to you.
But yeah this wouldn't be a Marvel movie without post-credits scenes
They want to make sure we learn the names of all 20 million visual effects artists
and yeah, obviously big spoiler warnings here,
not just for what's in the post-credits scenes
But for the whole movie of Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2,
and what might be coming up in future MCU films.
I'm just gonna be covering a lot of stuff,
so really you should just go watch the movie.
Don't get mad at me.
I'm sensitive.
Okay, so here we go.
James Gunn put five scenes at the end of this movie,
which rolled during and after the credits because
Oh why not?
First of these scenes shows the Ravager Kraglin,
who by the way is played by Sean Gunn,
brother of Director James Gunn.
He's wearing Yondu's head fin
and practicing whistling to control
Yondu's Yaka Arrow, given to him by Peter Quill after,
Pinned again one last spoiler alert here!
Yondu died
sacrificing himself to save Peter.
And of course shortly before that Yondu told Peter that
he actually controls the arrow with his heart,
[POP!]
not just the fin and whistling,
and that might be why we see the arrow
go way off target when Kraglin tries to use it,
right into Drax's chest
as Kraglin backs away awkwardly.
Now, I know
this is really just a funny scene,
but there may be some significance
to seeing Kraglin receive Yondu's iconic weapon,
like it could be implying that in
the third Guardians movie,
which is happening
[Smack!]
Kraglin might take over as the sort of successor
as the lawless, but pragmatic Ravager that Yondu always was.
It's also rumored that
Sean Gunn might appear in the Infinity Wars movies,
so we may be seeing him even sooner than that.
Okay, moving on.
This second scene shows Sylvester Stallone's character,
Stakar Ogord
assembling various Ravager leaders
to carry on Yondu's mission and steal some shit.
Okay, so who are all these people?
So, there is Charlie-27,
that's played by Vingh Rhames,
and Martinex is played by Michael Rosenbaum,
a.k.a. Lex Luthor from 'Smallville',
and then Aleta, that's Michelle Yeoh.
There's also Mainframe,
and I don't know if you caught this,
but that voice is Miley Cyrus.
Now, all these guys were actually
part of the original Guardians team
in the comic run in the 60s.
So it's pretty cool to see James Gunn bringing them all back together like this.
Also this red dude is Krugarr,
and notice how he's harnessing mystical energy
the same exact visual style of Doctor Strange.
And that's because in the comics,
this character is connected to Doctor Strange.
He actually succeeds him as the Sorceror Supreme.
Now, Stakar is a super interesting character
and the movie doesn't really get into his comic backstory,
like he's just a Ravager captain here.
But in the comics, he's known as Starhawk,
and his storylines involve time travel,
he actually relives his life over and over again.
Very cool character.
Now, I'm not sure if the third movie will get into all that stuff
or how much that movie will feature all of these guys.
But!
Gunn has said that he enjoyed working with Miley Cyrus
even though she just has like one line here
And he might have more in store for her characters
Okay, moving on a little later in the credits, things get interesting.
We see Ayesha licking her wounds, plotting her revenge,
revealing that she engineered a new being
that's the next stage of their evolution,
just to destroy the Gurardians.
Then we see this golden birthing pod
and we hear a faint heartbeat
and Ayesha says, "I think I shall call him Adam."
So she's obviously referring to Adam Warlock.
In the comics, Adam Warlock is also referred to as HIM
He's a genetically perfect super powerful being
designed by a group of scientists called the Enclave,
to be an even more perfect version of Ayesha.
She's actually called HER,
but now it seems like Adam Warlock's origin is being tweaked,
so that Ayesha created him,
like the superior race of the Sovereign is creating
an even more purely superior being.
Also, James Gunn has said that
that Adam Warlock cocoon easter egg,
that he put in the first Guardians movie
was kind of a mistake.
He just ment it as a joke then.
So that's why this cocoon has a
different looking design here,
now that the character is actually joining the narrative.
Now, Adam Warlock is an awesome character in the comics.
He actually plays a big role in the Infinity Gem arc.
Gunn actually wanted him to be in this movie,
but he felt that it already had plenty of other characters and storylines going on,
so he didn't want to overcomplicate things.
It also sounds like Warlock won't be part of the Infinity Wars movies,
but he will come back in Guardians the Galaxy Vol. 3
and one more quick thought on this.
Even though I doubt this is the case,
but if you remember, early in the film it's hinted that
Ayesha wanted to experiment with Peter
to reproduce the "old-fashioned way",
which I assume means like doggy style.
I'm a traditionalist.
Anyway, that never happens in this movie.
I'm pretty sure the Guardians leave Sovereign
immediately after that conversation.
But wouldn't it be awesome
if we later learn that it did happen
and part of Ayesha's formula for this superior being
included some of Peter's DNA.
I mean we do learn that he is the son of a Celestial in this movie,
like that could be part of the explanation of
how they're able to improve on their already kind of perfect genetic code,
and if so that would set up some more interesting
daddy issues with like Star-Lord and his son Adam Warlock, we'll see.
Okay, moving on.
This fourth scene actually does show what
Star-Lord as a father figure might look like.
We see Peter bickering with Groot,
who has now aged into this moody teenager.
His room is a mess covered in vines
and he sarcastically "I am Groot"s at Peter
as he plays a video game.
They grow so fast, don't they.
Yeah Peter, don't look too closely around that room.
You might find some tissues with tree sap in it
[Gross!]
But seriously Groot is growing super fast.
Like he was just a potted plant a few months earlier in this timeline,
and then now he was a baby in this movie,
and it sounds like we'll see an even more fully
formed version of Groot, beyond his size in the first movie.
Moving on to this final scene, which plays actually at the end of the credits.
It shows Stan Lee in his fishbowl helmet spacesuit rambling on with these guys.
Now these are Watchers
In the comics, they're all seen cosmic beings who observe intelligent life throughout the universe.
Now if you remember this scene is a callback to the earlier Stan Lee cameo,
where Yondu and Rocket are passing through various dimensions,
including one with Stan telling the watchers about
the time he was a FedEx guy,
referencing his cameo in Captain America: Civil War
And now, they're just like "Peace!" and they leave him behind without a ride home.
Now It's actually pretty interesting to see Stan Lee hanging out with the Watchers
because here's a weird theory.
In the comics, there's the Watcher character Uatu,
who's kind of the main one.
And it's possible that Stan Lee wrote himself into the comics as his character
because think about it.
Stan Lee shows up in so many different
superhero universes,
he's kind of liked his own Watcher in the cinematic world.
It would explain how he's able to break out of the MCU,
and then suddenly show up hanging out with Spider-Man.
And before you judge me, this theory isn't too out there.
One person who does agree with it
and did put this connection in there for that reason is James Gunn.
Okay! So those are all the post-credits scenes for Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2,
but keep an eye out for more videos that we got coming out for this movie,
including a full breakdown of all the easter eggs and the awesome song choices in this movie
Like yes, they are fun and catchy but they also have a deeper layer of meaning that connects to why the characters are doing things.
And if you like this video, please hit like and subscribe to New Rockstars,
and share this video with all your friends.
You can also contribute to us on Patreon.
Thanks so much to all of our current patreons, especially my good buddy from college, Chris Kell.
Dude, let's catch up!
I think I stole one of your shirts.
Anyway Chris and everyone else watching, you can hit me up on Twitter @EAVOSS
with any thoughts you have about Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2.
Let me know what you thought of it.
I love this movie. I can't wait to talk about it more
You can also follow New Rockstars on Twitter @NEWROCKSTARS for general updates on all of our videos.
Alright, thanks for watching! Bye.